Now, let me introduce you to the mystery test function.
This is a function which returns either pass or fail.
We would like to use fuzzer input in order to make it fail.
Here's some fuzzer input, which we can pass to mystery test.
Let's see where they passes or fails on that. Well, for this input, it passes.
We now, however, is again a fuzzer generated input for which mystery test now fails.
The first input passes, but the second input fails.
So you wonder what it is in this input that makes a function fail.
How can you find this out straightforward--by using delta debugging in order to simplify the first input
such that you know which part of the first input actually causes mystery test to fail.
And here is programming exercise, find the minimal input that causes mystery test to fail,
and for this, use a fuzzer such that you'll find input that causes mystery test to fail.
And once through fuzzing you found such an input, use delta debugging in order to minimize the input.
Over to you.